For the owner of a call
option with a $50 strike
price, then the payoff at
expiration ... we're talking
about the value of that
position. If the stock
is below $50 we wouldn't
exercise it, because we
can buy it for cheaper
than the option that the
call option is giving us.
If the stock goes above
$50 we would exercise
our option to buy at $50.
Say the stock is at $60
the underline stock is
at $60 on that date at
the expiration date,
then we would exercise
our option to buy at $50
and sell at $60 and make $10.
We would essentially get
this upside above $50
on the stock. If we think
about ... this is the
actual value of the
position, if we want to
factor in how much we paid for the option,
we would shift this down by $10. As the
holder we would pay $10
for that. It would look
this this. We would
essentially ... if we don't
exercise the option we
loose the amount of money
that was a loss that
we have to pay for the
option. Then above that
we break even at $60
dollars, and then we
make money above that.
At $60 the value of our option is $10, but
we paid $10 for it. That's our break even,
but then we make money after that.
This is from the
perspective of the holder.
perspective of the holder of
the call option. This is
the holder of the call
option. What would it
look like if you're the
writer of the call option?
If your the person selling
the right to buy the stock.
If this person right
over here, if the holder
has the right to buy
at $50, someone must be
selling them that right.
Someone must be agreeing
to say hey I will
essentially sell that to you
at that price.
If you're the writer
of the foot ... we have
the holder in green. The holder in green.
What if you're the
writer? You're essentially
the counter party on
that option. You're the
person agreeing to uphold that option.
If the option never
gets exercised, then the
writer doesn't have to loose any money.
If the option does get
exercise, then all of a
sudden, the writer starts to loose money.
If the writer doesn't
own the stock, and let's
say the stock is at $60,
this guy, the holder,
can exercise his option
to buy at $50. The writer
would then have to go buy
the stock on the market
for $60 and sell it for
$50. They would loose $10.
The writers payoff would
look something like this.
Once again it's the
mirror image of the payoff
of the holder. If you
think about the profit of
the writer, if the option
is never exercised,
then the holder gets to
keep the $10 that they
were paid ... that they
sold the right for.
If the option is exercised,
and they start to
loose money, and their
break even once again
is at $60. Anything below
that, then they start
to loose more and more
money. Once again these
are the mirror images of each other.
If you were to add up
these two line it would
be break even. These
parties are the ones who
are exchanging money between. If this guys
makes $10 this guys
loosing $10 or vice versa.